don't run
body camera video shows what happened
before a deadly standoff in Florida when
officers attempted to take a suspect
into custody officials say the same man
would go on to shoot two police officers
dude you're already going to jail don't
make this worse
the video stems from a June 30th
incident on the University of Central
Florida's campus officials stopped
28-year-old Dayton veal for driving a
vehicle with a stolen license plate
yeah
and then to step out come talk to me
step out come talk to me
you have anything on you okay this tags
come back has stolen man I'm Sergeant
lock from the police department
tag is coming back has stolen step over
there for me okay do you know anything
about that
you have a license on you I got my I got
everything in the cuddle okay don't
don't go and reach for anything yet
whose car is it you can open the door
you have any weapons in there
okay whose car is it tomorrow okay why
would the tag become back as stolen
video shows veal speaking with officers
explaining what he says happened you
Sergeant yeah yeah
I'd appreciate it yeah yeah what's going
on all right so all right so this is my
early personal don't reach for anything
no no don't don't reach for nothing okay
here you go
so I'm staying um
foreign
we have cameras on campus that pick up
license plates and it's been come back
stolen all night so you can see I I came
and I picked my girlfriend in the towels
I'm going right back here on Alexia
so you said you were going to be honest
with me so yeah so here we go I can show
you my ID and everything like that you
can run the van he will actually let's
go move in I'm gonna build my license
plate you can smell me I still okay
remember I don't know you we're not
friends yet okay okay
you just got out there and did it for me
so I might as well be honest with you
okay
if it's
yourself
[Music]
that's officer angle hang with him for a
minute okay
did Miss reveal yes so cool okay same
tight
I'm gonna use it to call your ID in
I'll give it right back okay
b400 I won't be able to memorize that
I'm looking at it
supports India Florida
after this the officer can be heard
calling in
information
Victor
400-177-94-3710 and run them all the way
please
I figure everything out thanks
I told him that vehicle comes back to a
2016.
so can I guess you got no insurance
right
yeah I ain't gonna lie to anything I
know Assurance lab money and I know I'm
not really supposed to be driving okay I
know I appreciate you being honest with
me because they don't make no sense bro
I already got you yeah they don't make
no sense but um
well don't worry we're not going to tell
her later veal clarifies everything that
happened but what's what's tell me the
whole thing straight through say the
whole thing beginning to end yep all
right so I got pulled Maybe
maybe a month ago
I put my car on ice now I'm working but
we just moved to a little house so I
ain't really got the money
it's her birthday like it's her birthday
so she wanted to to get out house she
don't have a car she live on campus okay
I'm right here on Alafaya right here
behind uh the ABS the 80s yeah yeah I
know I'm going right there that's
exactly where I'm at I go pick up last
night come back she stayed the night and
then I just drop it back off okay
literally and you were heading back
there and I'm just going to go park up
so I don't I don't be moving or not like
that but last night since it was her
birthday
you know so that's what's going on but
that's me that's my VIN number and
everything like that we got that all the
way you sorry so it don't make no sense
for me to you know what I'm saying even
if it was him he'd have to come for you
to do some extra all right
it's then that officers attempt to take
veal into custody because you got to
work for your rats don't run at this
point veal runs from officers who warn
he's going to be tased if he doesn't
stop
thank you
yeah dude you're already going to jail
don't make this worse the chase
continues for almost two more minutes
before veal gets in the car and takes
off again
don't run the other side
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we'll meet you Allison
what
[Applause]
foreign
magazine
let me find my stuff
all my mags fella
now you said he lives behind the Apes
months later on August 4th investigators
say veal shot two Orlando police
officers who are investigating a
homicide right now they're both in
critical condition veal was shot and
killed the following morning in a SWAT
standoff after barricading himself in a
hotel room reporting for lone crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie